David Fincher's psychological thriller
Fight Club was an enigmatic ride that
still leaves audiences scratching their
heads upon review the 1999 pick ended
with a twist and a bang and undermined
everything we thought we saw before the
final act to clear up any lingering
confusion about this modern classic
here's a breakdown of what actually
happened at the end of Fight Club with a
real Tyler Durden please stand up early
on in Fight Club were introduced to Brad
Pitt as Tyler Durden
a buff tough and rough guy who lives and
breathes chaos how's it working out for
you he befriends our sleepless narrator
played by Edward Norton and the to cook
up a plan to wage war on the ills of
capitalism only as we discover in the
final act Tyler isn't real he's the
human embodiment of a frustrated
corporate drones desperate yearning to
destroy the system that's confined him
if Fight Club were shot from a
third-person perspective it'd be the
story of a mentally unbalanced man
leading a bizarre double life by day
he's a bored office worker by night he's
a charismatic cult leader who likes to
punch things but thanks to the movies
unreliable first-person narrative we see
Tyler like the narrator sees him as a
charming nihilist who gets the girl
it takes Norton's character awhile to
figure everything out but eventually he
starts to realize that he's Tyler she
just called me say my name Tyler Durden
Tyler Durden that's when he confronts
Tyler and he discovers that he created
this man in his own image or at least
the image of what he wants to be all the
ways you wish you could be that's me I'm
free in all the ways you were not so
basically Tyler is a hallucinatory
hitmen hired by the narrator's
subconscious to blow up his life and a
few other things along the way all the
clues Fight Club doesn't tip its hand
much when it comes to foreshadowing it's
big twist
but Tyler Durden actually appears on
four separate occasions before we ever
really meet him in the form of single
frame blips on the screen and re-watched
these moments are meant to be clues that
Tyler isn't a real person and it's no
coincidence that our first glimpses of
Tyler come in the form of subliminal
messages since you like to add
subliminal private parts to movies in
this night job as a projectionist by the
time he makes his grand entrance as the
narrator's airplane seat mate you kind
of feel like you know him nobody knows
that they saw it they tape it what a
fight clubs niftier tricks is that
despite being the film's two central
characters Tyler in the narrator almost
never interact with each other in front
of anyone else but one notable exception
is a moment that takes place about
two-thirds of the way through when
they're in a car crash along with two
other members of
mayhem on first watch the scene seems
like a couple spat of sorts between the
narrator and Tyler with the mechanic and
staff playing the part of a bizarre
Greek chorus in the background but if
you delete the narrator's half the
dialogue the scene still totally works
as an illustration of indoctrination in
action
let go right fine after the accident
it's worth noting that Tyler emerges
from the passenger side and pulls a
narrator from the driver's seat showing
once again that Tyler was never really
there We Need to Talk About Marla as far
as the narrator's concerned Marla is a
nuisance and an interloper who's noisy
sexual relationship with Tyler keeps him
awake all night but for Marla's point of
view the narrator and Tyler are one in
the same which actually goes a long way
toward explaining why she continues to
maintain a relationship with him the
Tyler Durden Marla knows is moody
emotionally unavailable in kind of a
jerk to her as far as Marla's concerned
though Tyler is a perfectly ordinary
breed of bad boyfriend and one who's
good enough in bed to be worth the
continued emotional investment he met me
the very strange time anomaly after all
they started out as just a couple of
group therapy tourists so they were
equally messed up from the get-go his
Tyler dead in the final moments of Fight
Club
the narrator decides to rid himself of
Tyler once and for all by shooting
himself by doing so he simultaneously
takes and surrenders control and is
reborn into one whole self to improve
lost everything free to do anything
for all intents and purposes Tyler
Durden as the narrator knew him is dead
and the real Tyler is free to be whoever
he wants to be with Marla I decide he
watches calmly his Project Mayhem
reaches its inevitable conclusion but
the point of Project Mayhem was to
destroy all debts so that civilization
could start anew without everyone being
so beholding to consumerism
appetising has is chasing cars and
clothes working jobs we hate Sweden but
we don't need and since this was just
the first of many groups going forward
with the plan for apocalyptic
destruction to dismantle the system
after the credits roll
Tyler Durden slag acetal is on for good
or for ill thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel let's check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]